de San Patricio pasamos ahora a economía
ya está con nosotros en el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches y
comenzamos hablando con de ese informe
de la ocde y sus previsiones para la
economía mundial positivos o negativos
Bueno hay cifras positivas pero también
hay una gran advertencia señales
positivas como la reducción de los
precios de las materias primas o la
reapertura de China Después de tres
largos años de restricciones por Kobe 19
Pero hay una amenaza persistente la
inflación subyacente esta medida que
excluye a los precios de los alimentos y
la energía y que regularmente marca el
ritmo de la inflación general esta
inflación está aún por encima de los
objetivos de los bancos centrales esto
hizo que desde hace un año los bancos
centrales del mundo emprendieran un
ciclo de endurecimiento de la política
monetaria que se tradujo en subir los
tipos de interés o ponerle más precio al
dinero esto con el objetivo de
desacelerar la economía y bueno se
preguntarán por qué querrían desacelerar
la economía básicamente por los
desequilibrios en los precios la
doctrina económica adicta que al subir
los tipos de interés las personas
consumen menos y Esto hace que los
precios bajen Al haber menos demanda de
estos mismos productos de esta forma
disminuye también la cantidad de dinero
circulante pero como vimos en la Gráfica
anterior este proceso Aún es lento y ya
se comienzan a ver los efectos de ello
como las quiebras bancarias en Estados
Unidos escuchemos si que decía eh los
representantes de la ocde
las perspectivas económicas son
ligeramente más optimistas pero siguen
siendo frágiles
por un lado consideramos que la mejora
de la confianza de las empresas y los
consumidores el descenso de los precios
de los alimentos y la energía y la
reapertura de la economía china
repercuten positivamente en las
perspectivas económicas mundiales por
otro lado los riesgos siguen siendo
demasiados a la baja algunos riesgos
clave como las perturbaciones
persistentes a gran escala de los
mercados energéticos y alimentario se
han mitigado por ahora
porque a propósito de esas fluctuaciones
que ha tenido el sistema financiero en
Estados Unidos que dicen entonces los
bancos en la región bueno por ejemplo en
México el sistema bancario dice que ese
país solo verá pasar esta crisis
financiera de hecho es posible que las
entidades bancarias en América Latina
salgan ilesas de la crisis el grupo de
bancos mexicanos que estos días celebra
como una convención afirman que allí
cuentan con gran liquidez por lo que es
muy probable que México solo vea pasar
este suceso como lo hizo durante la
crisis económica la crisis financiera de
2008-2009 según varios analistas la
diversificación de los negocios las
regulaciones así como la experiencia
también en inflación y tasas de interés
altas estarían brindando a las entidades
del continente frente a las turbulencias
globales por ejemplo Pese a que los
valores financieros latinoamericanos se
han caído como consecuencia de esta
crisis de confianza en Estados Unidos y
en Europa el indicador msci emerging
Market que captura la representación de
capitalización grande mediano y pequeña
en 24 países de mercados emergentes solo
ha visto una pequeña fracción de la
caída de los bancos en Estados Unidos
Jorge y justamente en este momento de
coyuntura de incertidumbre y cuando
Estados Unidos ha tenido que intervenir
y rescatar algunos de estos bancos y a
sus ahorradores porque el bitcoin Está
repuntando bueno hace solo unas semanas
recordarás que el bitcoin había a
máximos históricos desde el 50.000 que
había registrado en 2022 pasó hasta
17.000 tan solo este año pero el
escenario cambió porque según expertos a
medida que la economía se encamina hacia
una recesión las criptomonedas se hacen
más atractivas que la renta variable
ahora mismo da la impresión que los
riesgos a la baja son mayores para el
smp500 que para el bitcoin Por ejemplo
si el primero de enero un inversor
compró 100 dólares en bitcoin y otros
100 dólares en un fondo indexado de lesa
en p500 la inversión en bitcoin le
habría reportado unos 60 dólares de
ganancia frente a los dos dólares de La
Apuesta por Alexa en pi la reserva
Federal que se reúne la próxima semana y
tomará una decisión sobre Qué hacer con
los tipos de interés de referencia que
es un dato que por supuesto siguen todos
los inversores durante la mayor parte
del año pasado el aumento de los
rendimientos del tesoro junto con el
aumento de las expectativas de su vida
de tipos de interés de parte de la Fed
fueron un problema para el bitcoin pero
las respuestas de que la Fed recortaría
los tipos de interés son buenas noticias
ahora para las criptomonedas Aunque una
recesión severa sería sin duda alguna un
problema para todos los activos de
riesgo incluido el bitcoin cifra del día
para el cierre tiene que ver con esta
crisis bancaria son 600 mil millones de
dólares en valor de Mercado eso
perdieron los 70 mayores bancos de
Estados Unidos y Europa desde el 6 de
marzo en este periodo sucedió por
supuesto la quiebra de silicon y de
signaturbank mientras Creed Group
recibió un salvavidas de 54 mil millones
de dólares del Banco Nacional suizo y
otro banco estadounidense el First
Republic Bank y recibió también unos 30
mil millones de dólares de parte de Wall
Street Jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización de las noticias del mundo
de la economía a continuación en directo
América ya llega una semana en el mundo
[Música]